thanks to Skillshare for keeping legal
eagle in the air learn to think like a
lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
turner Tenny better known by his
fortnight name of T Fuu started a
firestorm by accusing his Management
Group faze clan of an oppressive labor
contract what is he complaining about
and is the contract really that bad or
is T Fuu just a greedy gamer who was
bitter about signing an unfavorable
contract the answer could end up setting
legal precedent that will determine the
rights of thousands of professional
gamers all over the country hey legal
eagles it's time to think like a lawyer
today we are adjudicating the case of T
Fuu vs. faze clan you may know the
background here hundreds of millions of
people love playing video games their
passion for gaming has led to the
creation of a new industry known as
eSports which allows players to play
competitively for cash prizes eSports is
a multi-billion dollar industry
professional gamers in 2019 can make
millions of dollars live in fancy
mansions fly on private jets and make
plenty of money investors are looking to
cash in as well and are pumping hundreds
of millions of dollars into the eSports
industry which promises to establish
videogame leagues that will eventually
rival professional sports in revenue and
public attention and when there's
billions of dollars at stake that can
only mean one thing lawyers which of
course leads us to the matter of T Fuu
vs. faze clan or is it fuzz a clan
capitalization is apparently hard with
these people at any rate if you're
watching this video you probably already
know who T Fuu is he is a 21 year old
gamer who is currently one of the top 49
players in the world T Fuu regularly
wins fortnight tournaments has made over
half a million dollars in prize money in
just 29 tournaments he has his own
YouTube channel and is far and away the
most watched fortnight's streamer on
Twitch all of this makes him a star on
the rise in the eSports world if you're
watching this video you probably also
know who faze clan is it may sound like
a mid 90s hip-hop collective but faze
clan is actually one of the biggest
brands in esports faze clan bills itself
as a professional eSports organization
it has its own
or teams with players who compete in
tournaments for fortnight Call of Duty
and Rainbow six face clan also sponsors
events it has its own twitch and YouTube
streams topping it all off faze clan
purports to be a lifestyle brand which
sells t-shirts and hats and other items
as well in 2018 faze clan sought to
partner with tee foo culminating in a
contract a quote gamer agreement for t
food to play for their league when T foo
signed the gamer agreement with phase
back in 2018 he wasn't quite the star
that he is now but by 2019 T foo was
dominant at fortnight and has a growing
personal brand which gave him more
opportunities and endorsements outside
of the faze clan umbrella this is
probably where the party's interests may
have started to diverge T foo was
unhappy and said that the gamer
agreement that he signed forced him to
remain with the team for three years
stuck in with a salary of just $2,000
per month and let them keep 50% of most
of the fees and 20% of his prize money
he also said that the contract allowed
faze clan to take up to 80% of any brand
deals that were made for T Fu's personal
channels that means that if t foo signed
a deal to run an ad on his personal
YouTube channel faze clan would get to
keep most of the money the founder of
faze clan
Ricky Banks accused T foo of being
disloyal he said that the company hadn't
taken the 20% cut of prize money it was
entitled to under the contract banks
said that despite the contract terms
faze clan hasn't collected any revenue
from T Fu's tournament earnings twitch
revenue YouTube revenue or any other
source banks asserted that his company
had only made $60,000 on T foo since the
contract was signed t foo characterized
the contract as oppressive since he's
locked in for 3 years an initial
six-month term plus an additional 36
month extension which faze clan has
already exercised which means that he
can't compete for other teams this is
about me in this contract this contract
that I signed when I didn't know any
better I'm an idiot
I should have never signed in the first
place this three-year contract T foo
then initiated two legal proceedings
against faze clan first he sued faze
clan in court and filed a petition with
the California
labor commission the petition with the
California Labor Commission alleging
that phase is acting as an unlicensed
talent agency in violation of California
labor laws which are meant to protect
entertainers from gross exploitation the
petition asks the California Labor
Commission to require the state to
regulate faze clan like any other talent
agency and we'll come back to this later
the second action was a standard lawsuit
filed in a Superior Court for Los
Angeles County in at t foo raises seven
claims against Faye's claim a claim or a
cause of action in a lawsuit our
separate independent reasons for why a
party asserts they're entitled to win
the lawsuit it's normal to put more than
one of those claims or causes of action
in a lawsuit even if the whole thing
sounds in breach of contract as T Fu's
claims basically do here so first T foo
is asking the court for what's called a
declaratory judgment about the status of
the gamer agreement that he signed a
declaratory judgment is when the court
issues an order determining the
relationship between the parties a
declaratory judgment is a binding
opinion about the rights and
responsibilities of two parties often
you'll see this in a breach of contract
case where the contract actually hasn't
been breached but it will be depending
on the different interpretations of the
two parties in that kind of a case you
go into court asking for an actual
declaration even before the damages
haven't necessarily arisen T foo says
that faze clan materially breached the
agreement by accepting money from third
parties for sponsorships of T foo
involving modeling jewelry and apparel
but according to T foo after he provided
these services faze clan did not
distribute any of the money to T foo in
accordance with the agreement T Fu's
asking the court for a declaratory
judgment that the contract was breached
by faze clan and is now void so he can
get out of any obligations he has to
fulfil the rest of his contract term the
second claim is a claim for declaratory
judgment that the clauses in the gamer
Agreement which pertain to exclusivity
and matching rights violates section 16
600 of the California business and
Professions Code California is very
hostile to any agreement that purports
to limit a person's ability to practice
their profession the contract has a
six-month Don compete
claws following termination and
generally non-compete clauses are
illegal in California except for when
you have a non-compete with an equity
partner or like a CEO as a result it's
very difficult for any non-compete
agreement to pass muster under
California law but there's also an issue
in terms of whether you can just void
the contract provision itself or whether
you have to avoid the entire contract in
general here section 16 600 states that
every contract by which anyone is
restrained from engaging in a lawful
profession trade or business of any kind
is to that extent void under the gamer
agreement t foo cannot contract with
another gaming company without faze
clans consent T foo characterizes this
and other sections of the contract as an
illegal restraint on trade and
anti-competitive behavior that violates
section 16 600 the third claim is for a
violation of California business and
Professions Code section 17 200 which
precludes a person from engaging in
what's called unfair competition all
California lawyers know business and
Professions Code section 7203 very well
it's basically a catch-all for any shady
business practices it applies to any
unlawful unfair or fraudulent business
act or practice and unfair deceptive
untrue or misleading advertising T foo
alleges that phase clan's business
practices embodied by the gamer
Agreement have restrained his business
caused him financial losses and
threatened to cause other damages t foo
wants the court to stop phase clans
business practices and pay him
restitution for any revenue and profits
that faze clan made from these business
practices one of the reasons you would
assert a claim under Section 17 200 is
that it gives you what are called
restitution damages which are not
necessarily the same as contract damages
T Fu's fourth cause of action is for
money that faze clan collected for
sponsorship deals that it did not give
to t foo the fifth claim is for quantum
merit quantum meruit
is a latin term that means as much as he
deserved it is an action to recover the
reasonable value of services rendered by
one party to another tpho alleges that
he provided services to faze clan and
other sponsors and that those companies
benefited from those services
the tea Fuu did not receive compensation
for the value of those services the six
claim is for breach of written contracts
in this claim t Fuu says that in the
event of the Court finds the gamer
agreement is valid and enforceable t Fuu
has done everything that was required to
do under the agreement while faze clan
has failed to uphold its end of the
bargain t Fuu is seeking money damages
for breach of contract finally T Fuu 7th
cause of action is for breach of
fiduciary duty regardless of whether
faze clan is considered a talent agency
- Fuu claims that it owed him a
fiduciary duty to act in good faith and
in T Fu's interest at all times by
refusing a deal to avoid making another
sponsor upset the complaint alleges faze
clan acted against T Fu's interest so do
any of these claims hold water well all
plaintiffs write their complaints that's
the document that starts a lawsuit in a
way that is favorable to their case and
almost certainly leaves out any
information that's favorable to the
defendant so you have to look at these
lawsuits with a grain of salt on the
bridge of contract allegations if true
they likely do give rise to a material
breach of the contract generally
speaking when one party has materially
breached the contract it lets the other
side off the hook for further
performance and given T Foods newfound
fame and success that's probably what he
cares most about to get out of this
onerous contract so he can work with
other people the section 17200 claim is
probably a catch-all in case the breach
of contract claim fails the quantum
meruit claim is to recover any funds
that wouldn't already be covered by the
contract or if the Court declares that
the contract is void ab initio in other
words void from the beginning it's a
cause of action that would allow him to
recover what is fair even if it's not
actually covered by the contract but the
thrust of the allegations here are for
breach of contract asserting that faze
clan has breached the contract and
therefore T Fuu is free to work with
somebody else a lot of people have
pointed out how quote unfair this
contract is as a reason for why the
contract should be voided
but T Fuu isn't really arguing that the
contract is so unfair as to be legally
unenforceable
arguing as he probably should that faze
clan breached the contract and therefore
it's void there is actually a concept in
the law that voids a contract for
unfairness it's called when a contract
is unconscionable in making this
determination courts look at both the
substantive aspects of the contract are
the terms on their own unfair to one
party as well as the procedural aspects
by which the contract was reached did
the complaining party have the time
and/or resources to fully understand the
contract but you have to meet both the
procedural and substantive aspect of
unconscionability in order for the court
to declare a contract as void t Fu's
contract doesn't really fit that
definition there is no real evidence of
procedural unfairness like fraud or a
contract of adhesion sure the contract
sucks for T foo but it probably doesn't
fit the definition of unconscionable for
example people point to the 2080 split
of certain fees and winnings but that
only matters if t foo actually won
certain gamers might put great value in
the fact that they get a guaranteed
$2,000 per month and a court isn't
likely to second-guess that that's why T
Fu's attorneys don't even bother really
making the argument that this contract
is unconscionable
moreover T foo is a lot more famous now
than when he signed so like a rookie
contract in regular sports phase clam
would argue that the contract reflected
the party's positions when the signer
executed the contract and certainly the
uncertainty of actually working with T
foo at that stage in his career and in
addition to a guaranteed salary face
clan would argue that they gave him help
and invested in his future just like you
would in normal sports when you take on
a rookie performer but let's talk about
what potential defenses faze clan might
have to these assertions of breach of
contract
what does faze clan have to say for its
defense well first of all faze clan
disputes T Fu's characterization of the
gamer agreement noting that it has been
in negotiation with t foods and
representatives to offer him a new and
better contract faze clan says that its
previous legal team was responsible for
the 80/20 and 2080 split on profits and
after faze clan got new lawyers last
summer its new contracts reversed the
split so that the game
eighty percent of all of those deals in
phase clean only gets 20% phase client
states that just like any sports team or
movie company or record company its
original deal with its gamers is based
on their talent and their perceived
value of that talent at the time of the
contract like any entertainment company
or sports team faze clan looks to
renegotiate a deal when the talent
starts to dramatically improve and this
is what the company alleges it is done
with t foo now this isn't terribly
relevant to t Fu's allegations that faze
clan actually breached the contract that
they in fact executed it's in fact sort
of an admission that their current
contract is unfair but since T foo isn't
really arguing unconscionability it
probably doesn't hurt them too much to
argue the optics of things and say that
they're offering a new contract in
recognition of T Foods Fortnight
abilities faze clan says it has offered
him a seven-figure bonus and some
options that give T V 100% of any deals
they negotiated for him according to
faze clan t foo has failed to respond to
any or all of these overtures as early
as September 28th of last year we sent
the first revised version of a contract
for T foo we sent him a new agreement to
his lawyer January 24th of this year we
sent another updated thought on April
3rd then again on April 29th we gave him
so many different options that had
little or even some of them had no money
going to faze clan and yet we still
couldn't get a deal done and we come to
find that the reason why is he never
plan on getting a deal done with us he
wanted to start a competing organization
now whether T foo has ignored faze clans
overtures or whether he wants to start a
competing company as faze clan alleges
probably won't have much effect on the
lawsuit itself the future conduct of the
parties doesn't really have much bearing
on the actual facts as they exist now
and in the past faze clan also disputes
the notion that the contracts are
predatory in its Twitter statement the
company notes that over the last several
months it has encouraged any faze clan
member interested in hiring an outside
manager or agent to do so but faze clans
best strategy may be to actually lean in
to the draconian terms of the current
contract phase client recognizes the
50/50 split and sometimes 2080 split in
the contract it argues that it has never
collected its 80 percent now assuming
that faze clan actually upheld its end
of the bargain faze clan could be
entitled to that 80 percent that's
actually written into the contract now
that the parties have broken up and are
going their separate ways
faze clan could go after it's 80 percent
as written in the contract from t fou
after all what does it have to lose
countersuing for 80 percent would give
faze clan a bargaining chip against t
foo additionally since faze clan and t
foo were unlikely to ever get back
together faze clan will probably want to
counterclaim for any projected amounts
that t food would have made during the
remaining period of the contract because
we were having these issues and because
we wanted Turner to feel that we had his
back we made the decision to not collect
any money under the under the old
agreement nothing from prize pool
nothing from YouTube nothing from
anything except for a couple of brand
deals that accepted that we only took
20% of and those deals came from us to
him if faze clan upheld its end of the
bargain in the contract then it would be
T Fuu who is the one who was breaching
the agreement by failing to play for
phase which would make him liable for
phases expectation damages during the
remaining years of the contract of
course that is a big if in either case
faze clan will want to show that it did
not breach the contract while T foo will
argue that they did breach the contract
I can't opine on the likelihood of
either situation because I don't know
the underlying facts that's what the
lawsuit is for the crucial question in
this litigation is whether faze clan
upheld its end of the bargain and gave T
Fuu everything he was entitled to under
the contract the crucial question is not
whether the contract is unfair to T Fuu
now T Fuu also filed a petition with the
California Labor Commissioner here T foo
makes some bold allegations about phase
clans activities T Fuu says that he was
pressured to drink before he turned 21
and faze clan encouraged him and other
residue
to gamble while on phase clamp property
teef who says that faze clan pressured
and expected residents of the phase
house to perform dangerous stunts which
resulted in t foods permanent injury the
labor commission petition argues that
gamers are entertainers and artists who
must be represented by licensed talent
agencies under California's talent
agency Act which regulates the
relationship between talent agencies and
their clients for tea food to be covered
by the talent agency Act among other
things he has to prove that he falls on
the definition of an artist under that
statute to me the labor commission
petition seems like the tail wagging the
dog in this litigation though certainly
not an expert in this particular niche
of California labor employment law so
feel free to view my analysis with
skepticism here but I do know my way
around California litigation and when
you go to the trouble of filing a
lawsuit you tend to throw everything
that you have at it
some arguments are better than others
and to me it feels like the labor
commission argument is colorable but
it's really just there to back up the
main breach of contract claim it's
possible that this petition could have
wide-ranging effects on the professional
gamer community if the talent agency Act
is expanding to cover them but this
seems like a claim that is probably
going to settle before getting to that
stage and setting new law but we'll see
how it unfolds
now instead of watching video games have
you ever thought about designing your
own video game you could learn how by
taking brandon wu's class on making a 2d
platformer on Skillshare brandon takes
you through all the steps to building
your first video game with unity with no
coding required you could learn to make
the next fortnight or if you're more of
a fan artist you could take MS log
measure on six master class in pixel art
which will teach you how to draw sprites
right out of Megaman Skillshare is an
online learning community that has over
25,000 classes on everything like
lifestyle design technology business you
name it
there are almost 2,000 courses on video
games alone the first 500 legal eagles
will get to three months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below plus it
really helps out the channel the free
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to must know topics so you can
improve your skills and learn new things
all free for two months improve yourself
and you could make the video game that
takes
over the entire eSports industry so
click on the link below get two free
months of Skillshare and start learning
to think like a lawyer today it could
even help you become the next Sid mirror
so do you agree with my analysis
do you support T foo or faze clan I
think I know which way you guys are
gonna vote on that one leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real law reviews over here
where I analyze pressing issues of the
day like the Muller report and PewDiePie
so just click on this link and I'll see
you in court in the next one